hey this is presh hallwalker let s be
the sum of all positive real numbers X
for which
x to the power of 2 to the power square
root of 2 is equal to square root of 2
to the power of 2 to the power of x
which of the following options is true
a s is less than square root of 2.
b s is equal to square root of 2.
C square root of 2 is less than S is
less than 2.
d 2 is less than or equal to S is less
than 6. e 6 is less than or equal to s
this is a no calculator question and it
comes from a math Olympiad qualifying
question in America this is the 2021 AMC
12b problem 12.
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before I get to the solution it's a good
time to clear up a common misconception
when you have a to the power of B to the
power of C without parentheses you're
supposed to interpret this as right
associative or evaluate it from top down
so this is a to the power of the
quantity B to the power of C in general
this is not going to be the same if you
take a to the power of B first then
raise it to the power of C that's equal
to a to the power of BC
so in this problem when we have x to the
power of 2 to the power square root of 2
that should be equal to x to the power
of the quantity 2 raised to the power of
square root of 2.
so just something I wanted to say before
we get to the solution
so now to get started note that s is a
sum of all positive real numbers X that
means X is greater than zero and we can
use our normal exponent rules and
logarithm rules
to simplify this equation we'll apply
log base 2 to both sides
we can now bring down the exponents on
both sides of the equation
so we have 2 to the power of root 2
multiplied by log base 2 of X is equal
to 2 to the power of X multiplied by log
base 2 of square root of 2.
now let's analyze this equation
by simple inspection if we substitute X
is equal to square root of 2 we get that
both sides are equal to each other so X
is equal to square root of 2 is a
solution to this equation we've already
figured out one value
are there any others let's analyze this
equation further
we'll simplify the right hand side where
we have log base 2 of square root of 2.
square root of 2 can also be written as
2 to the power of one-half so this
simplifies to be one-half
now one-half can be Rewritten as 2 to
the power of negative one
and then we have 2 to the power of X
multiplied by 2 to the power of negative
1 and that is equal to 2 to the power of
x minus 1.
we can now simplify this by taking the
log base 2 of both sides of the equation
so let's simplify further
as before we can bring down the exponent
x minus one this will cancel out so the
right hand side is equal to x minus 1.
on the left hand side we have log base 2
of a product one term is 2 to the power
of square root of 2 and the other term
is log base 2 of X so the logarithm of a
product is the sum of the logarithms so
this is equal to log base 2 of 2 to the
power of root 2 plus log base 2 of log
base 2 of x
now we have 2 to the power square root
of 2 and we're taking log base 2 so that
will simplify to be square root of 2. so
we have square root of 2 plus log base 2
of log base 2 of X is equal to x minus
1. we subtract square root of 2 from
both sides so we get log base 2 of log
base 2 of X is equal to x minus 1 minus
root 2.
so now let's think about this
graphically
x minus 1 minus square root of 2 this is
a linear equation so it will look like a
straight line
now what about log base 2 of log base 2
of x
so we have the logarithm of a logarithm
curve so it's going to be a concave down
curve that's going to look something
like a logarithmic curve
now we know that X is equal to square
root of 2 is a solution so we substitute
it into the right hand side we have
square root of 2 minus 1 minus square
root of 2 and that simplifies to be
negative 1. so we know that square root
of 2 minus 1 is a point on the right
hand side but it's the solution of the
equation so it's also a point on the
curve on the left
furthermore if we test the value X is
equal to 2 we have log base 2 of log
base 2 of 2 log base 2 of 2 is equal to
1 and then log base 2 of 1 is equal to
zero so the point two comma zero is on
this concave down curve
so let's sketch a graph of the two
curves together
so we have the line which is going to
look something like this and we know
that one point is square root of 2
negative one
now we have the point two comma 0 and 2
is greater than square root of 2.
so we want to draw this logarithmic type
curve that goes through these two points
so it's going to go through these two
points and then it's going to grow at
some point slower than this linear curve
so it's going to intersect one more time
so let's say this point of intersection
is a comma B
what can we say about the value of a
well we see it's to the right of two
comma zero
so we know that the sum of the roots is
going to be square root of 2 plus a and
a is going to be greater than 2. so
let's look at our answer choices we can
immediately eliminate answer choices a b
and c because we know that s is going to
be equal to square root of 2 plus some
number that's greater than 2. so we're
just down to choices D and E
is s between 2 and 6 or is it going to
be greater than or equal to 6.
so how can we figure that out let's test
a value
what would happen if x is equal to 4.
well log base 2 of log base 2 of 4 will
be equal to log base 2 of 2 which is
equal to 1.
now if we substitute it into the linear
equation we get 4 minus 1 minus root 2
which is approximately equal to 3 minus
1.4 which is 1.6
so on the green curve we have the point
four comma 1 then on the blue curve the
linear curve we have 4 and something
that's about 1.6 this is larger
so we know that this will be to the
right of this intersection point in
other words x is equal to 4 is something
like this and a will be less than that
so we figured out that a is less than 4.
so now that means s is less than square
root of 2 plus 4 Which is less than six
and that means answer Choice e is wrong
and that leaves us with answers Choice d
2 is less than or equal to S is less
than six and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]